Jason from an actress perspective what
are you looking at in terms of old
footage what are you studying
everything everything get my hands on
one of the best things I've got my hands
on was some old sailing footage of Ted
and Joe sending the Y rowers of the
boats you know but they said why don't
you have a quitting you know just seeing
them that day on the phone
Ted on the phone in the gear young dudes
looking you know Ray Bans Joe is smoking
a cigarette bless sail on the boat you
know just you're looking for something
that captures you know then when they
they got that looking for both the
public one the unguarded ones the little
moments the mannerisms you know the
funeral is so much on these guys the
whole family well you know I watched a
lot of and read a lot of the other
brothers not just Tarrant is it over - I
went for the others I went for the
family you know and for what you knows
pictures in that of Joe you know how to
behave around your father you know
there's so much this and the particular
speeches some of the some of the most
some of the some of the greatest
speeches ever said and written
particularly by Bobby when did you know
you wanted to be an actor yeah we know
what I want to be an actor I think when
I when I decided I'd rather sit how much
movies and go to get university so
there's something in this and I really
wanted to be it when I couldn't you know
you you realized that you really want to
be an actor when you you can't quite get
there on auditions you're not quite
getting a job you just wanted you can
feel it I want to get in that door we
hear about the characters arc so when
you're about to go into production how
much you thinking of that and what was
Ted Kennedy's art a lot
Ted Gaines is huge um you're thinking
about that a lot I mean of course you
know the best officers you shoot you
know in sequence so you hear from one of
them but you never do that see having to
make sure that you know if from if I'm
ending here I'm starting there you know
you you try to give it the most it's can
see those are repeating it um so you're
really plotting that John and I did a
lot of work on that going over the other
scenes not just just rehearse them but
just talking over them rewording them
playing with them discussing them and
then Ted's Arc is a massive one you know
he starts off and he goes through
literally a sausage maker he's ground
down to come out that you know to that
final thing with a three to one the
pressures are
you forget that there was a live event
he got handed a punch up over it from
cards and it was oh there's no 15-second
pause it's on you know and here it is
your whole career your whole life your
family's your moral judgment your
everything it's down to this you know
sitting in a room with propped up on
books that I was a you know
Ted's journey of his own moral choice
and the choices that he made a to walk
away from the car you know doctor not
stop a dike house and knock on the door
or make a phone call at the bridge you
know it's a full-on journey of how he
justified this to himself and worked it
out or how he decided he wanted to live
or warrior was going to come around to
peace of a phone you know even the phone
when he goes to the police station he
calls the mother because he does know
it's the right thing to do they call her
up first and tell her rather than
somebody else so there's you know you
can it's just so much turmoil up and
down and dead before we get to the very
end you know and then I think that's
also reflected in society how does
society process this like it does and
all and still then continue to vote him
in right he still had to keep this
public face up which was so brilliantly
portrayed when you would walk down the
street and and he's ruminating about so
yeah I mean you got Ed Kennedy he wasn't
used to this I mean it's I mean is
anybody ready for the fact that you you
know you've gone away for a party having
a good night you know it's been a year
since your brother's been shot dead in
the head in front of everybody you're
catching up with some people that work
passionately on his on his thing you've
said a sailing boat you know you're
relaxed come over from from Washington
and all of a sudden bang you're upside
down on the bottom of a pond coming out
you know for length and then where's the
girl and then it's dark and cold and wet
that was an hour I walked that walk in
the night it's an hour an hour back to
the house you know give you a lot of
time to think you know how we learned
anything about this incident in terms of
how we view a tragedy how we view a
scandal have we as a society no no I
don't think so No